welcome to this video a new pod one
endgame strategy yeah I have to admit
that this is not a purely studi Jake Lee
focused endgame that's going to come up
but I still feel that belongs and this
category the series um
gap endgame why why is this an endgame
on the board it's not but it it can pop
up in a line that was possible in this
game this is the game between me ha ha
the former world champion and the black
player is Salix under cement yoke I
don't know that player really he didn't
even have any low rating he and when it
when this game was played in the early
80s but this does not mean much for
Russian players at that time they might
be very strong okay here tower played
Bishop c8 yeah interesting
technically justified move I don't want
to go through this in much detail it is
about the variation that could have
happened after Bishop c8 here the black
player plate King to h8 you know he did
not take the bishop if he would have
taken the bishop and that's what this
line here is what this makes interesting
for the endgame section is if he takes
we capture on c8 and I takes rook takes
rook evade in this position here in fact
White has a pretty similar wind with
Bishop takes e7 can briefly look at that
Bishop e7 rook takes and d6 and this
pawn is so strong it will promote
however another line that is given in a
book that I was looking at is it they
look at in this position and rook takes
of eight King takes two should be seven
King yourself
and here we got one of those end games
we have books tend to just ride or
commentators tend to just write and the
rest is a matter of technique yeah the
problem is that sometimes this kind of
thing is not so simple even if we here
enjoy the extra exchange how exactly do
we win the position and this is position
is what this video is about it's not
arising by force in this game or
anything so it's not so relevant from
let's say analytical point of view for
this game it is not an optimal variation
for for black force in any way but it's
so interesting to just look at this
isolated position and ask yourself okay
how is white actually going to win why
is it a problem we have an extra
exchange but the extra exchange is just
one thing we have problems and the
problem is we have a bad King our King
is not playing and it takes a moment to
get into the game I mean one move two
moves and so on so this takes about on
the other hand the black King is already
near the action it helps stopping the D
pawn and might get active on the Queen
side that's another problem that we have
our D pawn which is a passed pawn it is
supported by the rook but it's not just
going through promoting it's not so easy
black is on the other hand attacking our
b2 pond which is a bit weak and he's got
this Bishop on a great square on e5 in
well positioned Bishop very often can
compensate yeah for the loss of the
exchange of black would have some extra
pawn here it would be very very
difficult for white to do anything the
next thing that we need to be aware of
is that black has two pawns against one
pawn and he might get a passed pawn on
the Queen side supported by the bishop
the
is controlling the a1 square which is a
potential promotion square front for
those pawns so it is not super
straightforward the whole thing would be
very simple if we for example just just
change the position for for volume and
sake let's say we just do some magic and
look at this position here it would be
relatively easy for Y to win black has
no count to play and we can just yeah
activate our Kings somewhere on the
Queen side or break up the King side
with f3g for black ants no counter play
that's fairly simple but if we go back
to the to the actual position things are
not that simple so how do we approach
this position there is there's more than
one thing that we but we need to do we
should establish some sort of yeah some
setups that are good for us and some
that are not and what I mean we'll set
up this like porn formations if we look
at the position it is very debatable if
we ever should give up the b-pawn for
example if we give them two connected
passes difficult we probably should keep
the beep on that is one thing to look at
and also of course there are some very
concrete lines to calculate yeah for
example they move like rook a one comes
into consideration rook a one directly
attacking a seven there are some very
concrete lines that we need to calculate
but also as mentioned there are some
some structural things to consider if we
start with some concrete lines we can
maybe start with Luke a1 what our
candidates move here by the way we have
various candidates I think one possible
move definitely rook a one there also
might be rook see one yeah this is also
basically defending the b-pawn
tactically
as Bishop b2 rook c7 will regain us upon
so those two moves and another move or
moves that we need to consider is just
moving the beep on two squares on one
square if we look at this one by one we
will spend quite some time to calculate
however if we also consider some
strategic considerations we might count
to two a solution that wins quicker yeah
very often we have more than one way to
do things here you could do it in a
totally computer like brute force kind
of way or you could try to consider as a
set at the beginning to think about
about setups and things that are
favorable for us and things that are not
if we think about pawn structure the
move before gains quite some attraction
think about it if we go before we remove
this pawn from the attack which is good
so black cannot take it but we also
intend to change the pawn structure
considerably with before white actually
is threatening something what white is
threatening from a strategic point of
view threatening he's threatening to
play before to b5 putting this pawn on a
light Square where it fixes the a7 pawn
with the pawn being on b5 white does not
have to worry any more about any pawned
queening like a porn beef be pawn
starting to march down the board and
promoting at the end when the pawn is on
d5 the whole thing would be relatively
simple we should look at look at that so
maybe with some concrete moves
if black ignores this b5 idea let's say
a place came to d6 as some as one
possible nine came to d6 yeah what now
if we play b5 now black will play King
c4
that's not a good idea so we should if
we want to play b5 prepare that starting
with rook c1 and this is in fact after
Luke c1 leading to the exact same setup
that I was mentioning earlier white has
managed to push his pawn to b5 and when
this really has managed to diminish
blacks counter play considerably black
now does not attack anything on the
Queen side we have removed the beep
phone from the attack and our opponent
b5 makes sure that they a pawn is never
going to move as we always will be able
to capture it on Poisson so black has
won upon is won the deep horn we've
given up this pawn but in return we have
made sure that there's absolutely no
counter play very important of course is
that the rook here oops the rook is
creating a barrier for the King blacks
King cannot join the action on the Queen
side this way we have gained stability
in the position basically here we have
free reign without King we can really
take our time and activate our King
there there are ways more than one is
more than one way to do it we could play
King g2 and then play f3 and roll up the
King side or another way could be given
that we have time we can also consider
to just walk over to the Queen side and
maybe just protect this protect this
point and then enter with the rook we
have time we don't need to rush things
however if we look at concrete moves it
gets a critical for black very quickly
if we just continue for a bit and black
is basically only able to shuffle with
the bishop he has no active way forward
anyway in the in cases like that very
often the play will get concrete again
with white attacking the
horn be fired has fixed this a five a
seven weakness and now we can attack it
of course we could have done that
earlier but we wanted to get the King in
first now we actually can't play rook a
787 h7 just grab the whole thing like
this because our King is close enough to
help in the fight against the b-pawn
this makes things much much easier we
don't need to calculate anything
complicated here we just make sure that
we have our King defending against the
pawn and the rook will clear up the King
side so this is a fairly straightforward
win so if we go back in the initial
position thinking about the structure
here helps quite a lot as we identify
that before is really threatening this
b5 setup once we have established that
this b5 setup is winning we can pretty
much calculate the next lines quickly
because we need to first and foremost
check the responses public that deal
with this b5 threat so as we have seen
King d6 rook c1 is not doing very much
but what else is there that could go b5
okay after b5 however the pawn structure
has changed he has put a pawn on the
light Square and this is a pawn that we
can attack and we should start with this
pretty quickly just rook c1 again what
is our idea entering with the rook on c5
to attack this pawn or possibly on c6 to
go here those two things are possible
yeah here black when they cannot do very
much let's say came to d6
we then give this important check that's
very precise black grabs on d5 and we go
rook c5 to get the beep on note that
it's not a good idea to go for the a7
point
yeah we want to make sure that there is
no counter play coming up
if we go here we go to a six black takes
place King c4 rook a7 King before and
here again he's got the beep on it is a
matter of concrete calculation maybe
even win that but it's totally
unnecessary to deal with the whole issue
note that our King is not playing it's
totally unnecessary because if we are
cautious enough after King takes we're
not going to a6 we just do this blacks
King is going back and we take b5 and
here we have managed to trade off two
points the D pawn against the beep on
and this will win very easily note that
Luke a 587 is it's hard to stop even
here in this position and we will win
easily if we have the exchange up and we
only have the pawns on the King side our
rook will be the much stronger piece
then and win against the bishop it's
really about getting rid of the counter
plane yeah what else is there for black
it can play a 6 to stop b5 but again the
point is we have the C file rook c1 and
here really there's nothing nothing
great that black can do like King the
six directly we lose the two pawns and
there is no no really move here if we
look at this for example yeah we again
have a position where we have total
control we have the King Cairo on the
six rank we've kept the D pawn even and
we have stopped the a pawn it is just
yeah well stopped by the rook so an easy
win here as well yeah as we see before
is a very strong move and a solution to
this position before we win black really
has no way to defend himself against the
move we can look at a five if you want
as a final possibility
yeah and TM we we just need to take it
of course and now again make sure that
we get behind the pawn rook be one
attending rook d7 a7 rob6 a6 yeah black
has no way to activate the King if he
does something like that we will get to
a6 immediately or even after the capture
yeah take take this pawn yeah and again
here we've reached very simple winning
endgame now where we just activate the
rook they activate the King I'm sorry
and king and rook together will at the
end win those pawns or some of them so
a5 does not save black as well so B form
is a good solution to this and show us
that looking at some structural points
can even the the calculation
considerably however in this position
there are also some other interesting
moves if we want to complete the picture
a very good move as well is purely
tactically justify move if you want this
is rook a1
as mentioned earlier a candidate move
yeah why is this strong the reason is it
is a very concrete with a 7 hex with a
check and black has to address that if
he is taking on B - we will win very
easily we grab here and now we can just
go to b7 and when when very simply we're
doing the beep on or after King here we
will push our pawn and also win this
easily besides the fact that even taking
on h7 will win but the real deal after
rook a 1 the real problem then is not
the capture but a5 the problem is the
wrong word white is winning here as well
but it's more it's more testing than a 5
move yeah what now what is the big point
it is very important to BM to be very
cautious and alert here courses the
wrong word but we need to be aware that
black is
still having some counterplay if we go
and in the rook a3 here for example this
is a mistake intending to attack the
pawns something like this yeah this is a
typical case where we have misplaced our
own pieces the rook on b3 now has a very
sorry very sorry state
it cannot go here cannot go here if it
goes to a3 we lose the pawn on b2 and
black has a very simple plan pushing
pawns this can even get tricky for white
so caution in fact white has a win and
the winners looks you wanted yeah it's
quite funny rook a1 provoked a 5 and now
we go back to c1 why a 5 why is this a
good move to provoke now b6 is weak b6
is unprotected and we have a very
straightforward way to attack it yeah
this is in fact also quite a simple win
for white after Bishop b2 now we go
route b1 easy and now we went win the
pawn on e6 and again we can or we get to
the type of position that we have
examined before where we can show this
and here we even win the in pawn if I
was probably not the toughest what would
be we know the kind of position already
it is a winning position by the way here
that's also rupees six something should
be too is not not a problem at all
yeah rook C 1 what should like do rooks
is 6 is coming anyway another line might
be this and this is also getting to be
pretty pretty simple win where we have
traded off our weaknesses and we will
probably even get the e5 pawn so here in
this position they are basically two
solutions one solution is connected to
the move before as mentioned based on
this more strategically focused idea and
the other solution is rook a1 which is
more like a
really technically justified idea
however rue k105 clearly shows v6 as a
new weakness and is an alternate way to
win it is very often a good idea to look
at those positions that sometimes are
they in books on game commentaries where
they say okay well this is simple and
this is a simple technical task and it
might be for very strong players but
still it's a very useful thing to once
in a while look at those positions and
really ask yourself okay how am I going
to do that and if you want to practice
it you can do it of course against the
training partner human training partner
or if you really want to want to make
life hard for yourself yeah try to beat
a strong engine from a position like
that where you are supposed to win
easily technically and so on you will
find that very often the the first way
that you try it's not working but you
need to refine your play a bit to really
beat then the engines defense which very
often would be a close to perfect or
perfect defence hmm so I hope you
enjoyed this little game analysis
fragment from from it to a North Star
game that shows how to approach those
end games where you yeah should diminish
counter play and also think about your K
is not playing we need to be extra
cautious if the King is not playing yeah
I think a good example also to show how
some strategic considerations go hand in
hand with concrete and calculation and
and technical yeah technical precision
all right I hope you enjoyed it
thanks for watching